ladies and gentlemen Kevin Feige welcome
mr. [ __ ] how are you I'm very very good
good
hello now how are you how are you
feeling I was I snuck out there to watch
that piece with you guys because it
still blows my mind that guard is the
galaxy that comes out next Friday ah I
saw it by the way I went to that you let
me come to the premiere and it honestly
it is beyond any I swear I'm not just
saying that cuz you're here but James
Gunn is managed to make a visually
stunning film that is hilarious an
action it's a pop song go see it but it
is our tenth Marvel Studios movie the
tenth movie the tenth movie that takes
place in our cinematic universe and I
can't believe and I can't wait for you
guys to to see it because it always
starts in this room it always starts
with you guys in this room from jon
favreau walking out there in 2000
whatever six or seven it's just it's
been amazing and we put that piece
together just for this room and it's
very very cool what's exciting
particularly this year is we had a movie
called Captain America the Winter
Soldier guardians comes out this Friday
and I love the notion that you guys are
just as excited for a part two or part
three something that you've already seen
before the next adventure but you're
just as excited for something fresh and
something new with guardians and what
we're going to talk about today is 2015
where we're doing a very similar thing
we have a movie called Avengers age of
Ultron that comes out I've heard of it
and then we have something new ant-man
is finally coming out and you want to
meet some people involved in ant-man
alright
the director of ant-man Peyton Reed this
is the first time visiting comic-con for
both of the ant-man I'm about to
introduce you to Paul Rudd and Michael
Douglas Hank Pym Michael Douglas period
first time the villain of our piece his
name is Darren cross we also call him
the yellowjacket in the film Corey Stoll
and there have been some some rumors
recently about who's playing this part
in the film but now finally confirming
no more rumors playing the daughter of
Hank Pym hope Van Dyne Evangeline Lilly
your 2015 ant-man cast let's start with
um let's start with Peyton Reed uh who
if you had any question as to whether or
not Peyton might be the right guy for
this job uh what number of comic-con San
Diego International comic-con is this
for you Peyton Reed uh this is my 20th
anniversary visit to comic-con
1994 was the first summer I went to
comic-con it was here Jack Kirby passed
away and I have been every year since
then I think - a couple of years when I
was shooting and what was the punk band
in high school that you were in oh yeah
it I was I was a drummer for a time in
the 80s in a punk band called Jonny
Quest and and
hey you and in addition to being the
drummer I was in charge of drawing the
Flyers for the shows and we did a show I
think in 1988 and I drew a sort of a
ripoff of Avengers number one where all
the band members were members of the
Avengers and of course ant-man was an
original Avenger and I drew myself as
ant-man and I would love to
they bring that yet there it is yeah
there he is
that's that sweet new Jonny Quest LP
that all the kids are digging yes
there's gonna be a Betty green is that
you down on the drums
that's me flying on the twin snare drum
thing yeah my carpenter ant Payton did
not tell us this when he when we when we
met him for the job it wasn't until long
in T he's already been been working on
the film that he brought this out and he
didn't tell Paul I just taught Paul Paul
about and Michael about it yesterday
so his fandom runs deep I'll get you a
cassette of the amoeba I have a Walkman
right here I could totally play it I
could totally play it on the Marlin um
Paul Rudd congratulations to you you
never and you've never you never been to
comic-con you never sat up on this stage
before this is my first time here they
call that a comic-con virgin yeah I'm a
comic-con virgin what what
don't shout pop the cherry and that's
disgusting
I didn't even being how dare you that's
what it was
yeah I'm popping my comic-con cherry
this is it and it is as advertised this
is unbelievable if you're gonna do it do
it with 7,000 people hey right yeah um
so how does it feel to basically to come
in to the Marvel Universe as you know
what will probably be another like 10th
point like you're gonna be you're gonna
be this guy for a while like what does
that feel like it's a it's a mind bender
it's so exciting
I'm so honored to be a part of it it's
really thrilling and um and I it's it's
kind of tough to wrap my brain around I
mean I've been doing this as a job for a
while but this is a whole
other thing and and I'm excited by the
the challenges I'm thrilled to be
working with such great people and
looking forward to see seeing how it all
is excellent uh mr. Michael Douglas uh I
never thought I would say this to you
but we're also popping your cherry as
well um it's very awkward um but uh I've
hopped enough cherries I just don't
think I don't want to just talk about
that for the next hour um but what is uh
what is the experience been like for you
to come in as hank pym and what do you
what do you see what do you envision for
the character well you know I've always
by curiously looked at Marvel films from
afar with tremendous envy my entire
career has been making up of doing kind
of contemporary movies without any
special effects or anything to so to
have the joy and the love of all these
fantastic tools that so well done and
the ant-man stories is a wonderful story
and so to be surrounded with Peyton Paul
Evangeline Corey I'm just looking
forward to a real trip this is sort of
based upon a comic and started out in
1962 Stanley wrote about a dr. Henry Pym
who was an endocrinologist also this is
system it'll turtle just metal purchased
and basically developed a serum to make
a person reduce themselves to the size
of an ant but with the strength of a
human being and then went beyond that
more importantly to learn how to
communicate with ants because answer
armies and so this is the basically the
story of a heist of a pup his partner
Corey plays that role which has taken
the company
different evil direction and I have
found a mentor in Paul to take over my
position as ant-man the only trouble is
that Paul is in such great shape such
incredible shape that physique the
ant-man bodies who just didn't we had to
soften it up just make it look good
startling we're the first Marvel movie
that's uh spending a lot of money on CGI
to remove muscles from our Europe smooth
those out you know what most of that's
where most of the budget is going let's
just bring it down to a 4-pack Paul
Evangeline Lilly all who has been all
overhaul age today you've just been back
in the crowd and I was like hang on a
minute I saw these people this morning
oh yeah they see her okay they don't
leave guys gray wig you're the comment
girl in the front she always has
something to say but pop the cherry girl
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't want to be
repaired with that but uh tell us about
tell us about hope and dying and and and
what York space has been like so far my
experience so far has been just evading
the press that's been generally been my
experience on ant-man I've been at Comic
Con for two days now answering questions
about ant-man but officially saying I'm
not in ant-man um so I'm very glad to
announce it I'm super happy to be here
um I'm obviously playing hank pins
daughter hope him say that five times
fast
um and I can't tell you anything else
about her cuz I don't know I don't have
a script not yet now you're just at the
point where you can say that you're in
it hi I'm in it I'm here glad to be here
thanks guys
I mean this has really been an
incredible couple of years for you just
in terms of the scale of stuff that
you're working on so what is it
how are you kind of how are you how do
you sleep I talk I don't do a lot of to
me actually the last six months I
started learning um meditative breathing
practices swear to God just so I can get
some sleep I'm a mother I'm producing my
first children's book series and
finishing up the Hobbit series and
starting this one so I'm having a great
time Oh Khan is kind of my world I love
I mean everything it seems like
everything I've ever done on the screen
you guys are right in fray you're in the
mix lost right so I started here in 2005
and and I was in Hall H and we were
showing a television show that wasn't
even on air yet and you were still this
was still a packed auditorium so much
love to all of you I love my people uh
course all also here who's playing
character by the name of Darren cross
what can you tell us about Darren cross
Cory um I really I mean I think that was
about it
but well you know I am I was Hank Pimm's
mentee and the the genius scientist as
well and I am now I've taken over the
company and some very judgmental people
may think that that's in an evil
direction but I think I'm just taking it
into the into the future
what can you keV can you tell us
anything about Darren cross uh I think
he did it I think he did a marvelous job
he does at a certain point obtain some
Pym particles and and begins to give
ant-man a run for his money and again
puts on a suit that is called the Yellow
Jacket suit in the film and and causes
havoc so Darren cross actually will be
yellow jacket in the film which is not
previously announced now is it you have
to keep all this stuff in the entire
time so comic-con for you must be like
an incredible release where you can be
open about everything popping cherries
release I don't this is a family event
that Israelis get made that's how
families get made
yes some of them a lot of them tonight
7,000 families will get made tonight in
a weird comic-con pyramid scheme but you
guys don't uh you don't have any MN
footage to show yet right because you
haven't even started filming well no we
start filming in two weeks we start
filming on the eighteenth Monday August
18th in Atlanta come up don't come by ah
so no so we haven't we haven't started
filming the movie yet but we filmed a
little something to show you guys today
thanks to Payton thanks to Paul thanks
to Michael and thanks to some of the
visual effects tests we have in the
works here's a quick look at ant-man
ladies and gentlemen the cast of ant-man
now actually has to go make the movie
there they are
Ben Reed Paul Rudd
you